[Music]
experts say
school closures were a necessary evil to
slow the spread of the coronavirus
but they affected 80 percent of children
worldwide
forcing most to study from home placing
an extra burden on parents
modern technology helped in many cases
but not all
the pandemic could see millions of
children left behind
can generation covert make the grade
and what happens after school are we
talking about permanent damage
will this affect students chances on the
job market
all questions for our guest in a moment
first this report
seven-year-old ruskar is accompanying
his mother john dan goomberg to work
like most days due to the pandemic
turkish schools have been shut for over
a year
jandan runs a private kindergarten on
the outskirts of istanbul
they're occasionally allowed to open
unlike schools
her son attended school for six months
before authorities
ordered all schools closed
now rusgar spends his time at his
mother's kindergarten
or at home attending virtual lessons
something the second grader doesn't
enjoy
i preferred math classes in school
i liked it there even though teachers
sometimes got angry at us
for the past year remote learning has
been the new normal for ruskar
a challenging situation for him and his
single mother
ruskar struggles to stay focused in
front of the screen
he still can't read or write properly
the kids have lost interest in
everything they don't want to leave the
house anymore
and are losing touch with the outside
world
over 10 million turkish children and
teenagers haven't attended school
in months they're only allowed back
for exams like these pupils at an
istanbul primary school
many parents are fed up with the
government's strict stance on
education should be their top priority
instead we see them holding conferences
and party conventions without heeding
any corona restrictions
the education sector is being neglected
while most other european countries have
tried avoiding school closures
turkey's education and science workers
union warns turkish pupils are falling
behind
online lessons are not very effective we
have basically lost an entire year of
teaching
we never understood why schools
supposedly pose a greater infection risk
than cafes or restaurants
turkish school closures have hit poor
families like the aslan's
hardest some four million turkish school
children don't have internet access at
home
that means mohammed azlan must rely on
the educational programs on turkish
state television
people with money can send their
children to private schools and pay
tutors to help their children catch up
we can't afford that
our children have to resort to
educational television shows
wealthier parents like zhandan gunveren
are finding turkey's economic situation
increasingly difficult too jandan says
more and more parents are taking their
youngest
out of her kindergarten if the trend
continues
she may go out of business but
matters are even worse for turkey's
school children
they are the ones paying the highest
price in this pandemic
lanka is assistant professor of social
policy at the belgian university k.u
lurvin
so can we expect all these children just
to catch up
once the pandemic's really over or are
we looking at long-term
effects for example job prospects
well i have to say i'm afraid we are
looking really at these long-term
effects
in terms of educational attainment in
terms of job prospects
and if we don't try to mitigate the
impact of these school closures on the
most vulnerable children and students
i'm afraid we'll be jeopardizing their
future it's kind of well known
that educational attainment and in
particular your higher education
attainment
is really is really important for your
later job prospects
and so if those children don't have this
higher education attainment
you know they will have trouble finding
decent jobs
later on in their life and this might
reinforce this cycle of inequality that
we're witnessing
just how many children are we actually
talking about how many schools
were closed uh during the pandemic
well you know at the peak of the first
wave in april 2020 we'll be talking
about
one and a half billion children
worldwide who have been affected
by these uh by these school closures but
even today after a second wave and
sometimes a third wave
you know at the global scale we we still
see that over 200 million children are
affected and that their
schooling experience their learning has
been interrupted
and even today also in europe in
countries such as germany or belgium and
norway for instance
schools are still often partially closed
and many students still have to deal
with remote learning
so it affects a lot a lot of children on
a global scale
absolutely when we've been talking about
learning and
also the fact that these kids have been
having a hard time and having to catch
up but
what about something as important as
social skills that uh kids also learn
at school which are so important later
on in life
yes i mean i mean i mean i mean the
schooling outcomes are very important of
course but schools are more than that as
we all know right
also social places social environments
places where
children meet other children but
children play where children sort of
you know also can eat healthy for
instance that is one important function
of a school besides learning and
education and we know that school
closures have had detrimental effects on
that
on on that part as well on that account
as well and of course
affecting those most vulnerable children
those most disadvantaged children who
you
you know who stand to gain the most from
having
social contacts with other children so
this is absolutely a problem as well
besides you know
the learning outcome issue so give me
some
solutions what are we going to do about
this can can we change
the situation
well um i think you know one of the key
lessons that we learned
is if we switch to remote learning
learning needs to continue
i mean i'm absolutely convinced that
digital technologies offer a lot of
opportunities but
you know most schools and teachers were
not really equipped
with the knowledge and the right tools
to to offer high quality remote teaching
so one thing we need to do is we need to
really start improving the ict
competencies of teachers and schools
we need to invest in the digital
infrastructure of schools so
if we switch to remote learning that
learning can continue
for all children that all children can
access high quality
remote teaching but of course you know
we know that many children grow up in
disadvantaged families for
for instance in environments which are
detrimental for learning if you have to
follow online courses
with five children in one room for
instance you know it's it's impossible
to learn properly so
we need to make sure that remote
learning you know is
sort of adjusted to the situation of the
most disadvantaged
children one simple example can be if we
give assignments to children for
instance in a remote teaching
environment
make sure that it is possible it is
feasible for these children
to make their assignments on paper
that's one very simple solution that we
can implement
you heard it from von lanka thank you
very much for being on the show today
happy to be here thank you lots of good
advice there
time to hand you over to derek williams
again our science correspondent he's got
an interesting question today about
covid and age
how has the average age of patience and
the severity of covet 19
change since the beginning of the
pandemic
this is such a complex question on so
many different levels that it's
it's nearly impossible to really answer
adequately and i can't but i'm happy to
talk about
um why first saying that we can track
averages implies that we had adequate
surveillance measures in place
from the very beginning of the pandemic
but we didn't
it took months to get large-scale
testing
up and running even in the
industrialized world
so the statistics from the early days in
particular about
how many people of what age actually had
the disease
and and how badly they have to be taken
not just with a grain of salt but but
with a whole
handful of it and in many countries
those statistics still do then
there are a host of other
slippery variables for example that
doctors
have gotten a lot better at treating
covet 19
as the pandemic progressed and and they
gained experience with those treatments
finally the introduction of vaccines to
different age groups at different times
in different countries
that's also changed pandemic dynamics in
ways that make
blanket statements really just pretty
untenable
just to illustrate let's look at the
situation
here in germany one thing we know for
sure
is that the older you get the more
dangerous and potentially deadly
contracting coveted 19 becomes that
hasn't changed
what has changed here is that as the
vaccine drive progresses
an increasing number of high risk people
so
those over the age of 50 they're
protected
by vaccine-induced immunity in the most
recent wave in germany which is
hopefully the last
a lot of doctors anecdotally reported
that they believed
the average age of patients in intensive
care had
dropped pretty dramatically compared to
to earlier waves
but the actual statistics are kind of
hard to interpret one complicating
factor for instance
is that if a younger person ends up in
intensive care they're a lot more likely
to survive for weeks before
they recover or or die occupying a bed
for much longer than a more frail
elderly person
might but those kinds of trends are are
specific to here they can't really be
applied
to other countries because they depend
on a wide range of factors
everything from the state of hospital
infrastructure
to the vaccine priorities that germany
has said
for different age groups